daylight reveals the scene of the
disaster the driver of the passenger
train emerging from an underpass may
have had no time to react to the
oncoming freight train two mangled
engines testified to the severity of the
impact
all that's left of the front two
passenger cars is a pile of mangled
debris the third car partly on top of
them cranes delicately pick the wreckage
apart piece by piece just in case a
Survivor is found but hope is almost
gone
I don't think there are any others we've
looked everywhere I don't think there's
anyone left inside
survivors emerging in the immediate
aftermath of the disaster were trying to
understand what happened
then we fell down a woman with her child
was with us the train caught fire next
to us and this guy found a hole so we
all managed to get out
the whole train had bent 90 degrees and
had fallen over the cliff half of it was
hanging in the air and the whole thing
was on fire
there were five wounded where I was
the immediate blame fell on the Larissa
station Master arrested for manslaughter
he reportedly confessed that he tried
unsuccessfully to switch the passenger
train onto a different track as it left
the station not bothering to report that
the switches had failed and not
suspecting the horror that would follow
an estimated 82 passengers are missing
but only about half that number of
bodies has been recovered the rest may
never be retrieved because the fire that
engulfed the first two cars of this
train were so hot more than a thousand
degrees Celsius we're told it may have
cremated the victims exactly where they
were killed prime minister kiriakos
mitsataki says a commission of experts
will probe the causes of the accident
and lack of safety culture in the Greek
Railway Network John saropoulos Al
Jazeera larussa